let me put it to you this way
if if if what i have in mind takes place
over the next couple years two to five
ten years
we're going to create a business model
for bodybuilders to make the kind of
money they've never made before
they've never made before but in order
for that to happen we got to kind of be
able to have our own
contest like let's just say we were if
we were to run mr olympia
you just kind of threw this out there
and kind of my mind automatically went
there
if we were running mr olympia what i
would do to the mr olympia brand and i
know this sounds a little bit
too confident to say what i would do the
plans
we would put in place for mr olympia
bodybuilders
would be sitting there saying finally
somebody flipping did it
that you gave us a platform to make
money to be appreciated
to be in movies to have our message be
out there to be able to get sponsorships
to be able to live in
a place where we're making the kind of
to to be able to have our identity
change instead of just seeing a bunch of
muscle heads somebody's showing how
brilliant and intelligent we are to be
able to realize how technical this is
you're almost like a scientist to become
a bodybuilder it would change the game
because i think bodybuilding
is is a business model that can really
everybody in the world looks and admires
a nice six-pack everybody in the world
likes one of these when a guy flexes
dylan sees a muscle
i said dylan touch phil's biceps he
touches phil's biceps dylan's like
oh my gosh it's so thick
dylan says it's like i want muscles like
that right
watch what we're gonna do to the
bodybuilding world in the next couple
years hey
bodybuilders if you're listening up just
think about it if you're
if you had a full support management
you know somebody that's getting you out
there getting your exposure
helping you make money creating content
for you giving you millions on top of
millions of views
uh having you to get new opportunities i
don't know i want to stop right there
it's just if that ever came across
in your opinion what is broken in the
bodybuilding world that
pat even like a a businessman a
capitalist
who has never you know professionally
competed says i can come in and do
something better
which is sort of the story of capitalism
what is it that's broken right now what
needs to be fixed
direct connection meaning like um
what am i gonna get for what you're just
saying
these men and women i mean they put a
lot of time
a lot of effort and if we were to really
write it down how much money and time
that they put into their physique
they'd be so in the red the black that
you know people would say well how are
we going to sell this
you must really love this [ __ ] because
you're not making money from this
the biggest thing i i think is the lack
of opportunity for
athletes to sit at the table and i think
a lot of times
um you know the athletes like myself for
instance
when the magazines were going on i think
there was a lot more opportunity because
um
you know you're getting eyeballs on you
through the magazines when the digital
age came
there was really there was really no sit
down with all the
top athletes and saying like this is a
platform that we're gonna make for you
to make money
because a lot of you people didn't go to
college you didn't have you know these
conversations
we were just focusing on you know
training and dieting because that's
freaking hard
but right now we're i don't know i
nailed it i think we're at a great point
in time where we can have this
conversation but i think
in order for us to it comes out to die i
think we you know just need more
dialogue of saying like look you're only
making like like look like for instance
i went to a show last weekend i think
one of the girls she placed like third
in a
figure competition she only made like
500 bucks 500
how much did she have to invest to even
get to that point 20 grand in the year
easily easily so like what is her
motivation
what is her motivation when she comes
home she made more than that are only
fans dude
right that's a problem and that's a
problem so i mean i i think it's really
important that we we look at this and
say look like
i need to invest money in these people
so then they can actually do better
these are these are people that have
amazing stories these are people that
have
amazing triumphant stories and they and
they actually personal train people they
they train people through ebooks and all
these other they're very influential
but it's really hard to keep them
motivated and keep them locked in
for the long period of time when they're
not getting paid
i mean one of the girls that did the uh
miss olympia physique competition
shanique grant
very young you know bright star she won
the olympia a couple of times
if she was getting paid more money she
wouldn't have retired
now i understand she wanted to have a
family and stuff like that god bless her
you know good luck
with that but i guarantee you if she had
a couple zeros
extra she might say you know what
i'll have this kid but i'm coming right
back you know what you know what
confuses me the most here's the
following thing that confuses me the
most okay
here's what's confusing the most you
know a lot of people take shots at
uh ufc you know it's like ufc this ufc
dana white does dana white that
uh would you say dana white takes care
of his number one guys like does
god do his number ones make money yeah
yes
he's the number one he's not making
money how the hell is he not making
money
and i'm talking like he should make five
ten million a year
to be able to get the other guys to say
i want to be him yeah how the hell does
that even happen yeah
you got 16 different people in the
history of mr olympia that have won mr
olympia 16.
the last three years has been a person
that's wanted one one one anytime mr
olympia is winning one at a time
there is no legacy there is no
excitement do you want to see like a
stretch like oh my gosh i want to go see
ya's i want to go see eath i want to see
ronnie i want to see arnold i want to
see haney i want to see i want to see
the
i want to see cutler 4x like damn look
at cutler right one
two one two it's like dude look at this
stuff right when he's coming right i
want to see that
how does how do number ones why is it so
many guys that are number ones from mr
olympia how come how come
how come there are money i don't get
that so so the whole thing
where they say dana treats his athletes
like he owns them
mr olympia treat their athletes like
they own them and it's purely now this
is me my
this is not his position this is my
position he disagrees with me and he'll
say he'll defend the brand because the
brand has changed his life in many ways
this is me saying this
he this is not his position anybody from
astrology that's watching this pbd is
saying this he's not saying this
but i see it and i talk to a lot of the
guys who are bodybuilders who are
winners and i said how do i treat you
i've never heard anybody say they treat
me royally how the hell is that possible
everybody's like walking on eggshells
paid the damn number one guy
what are you doing how many interviews
have you done with the top bodybuilders
we have the most innermost views on
bodybuilding ever on all of us
and i've only done like 10 of them i
stopped doing them eventually i'm like
i'm done with this
but i tell you if the right owner
ownership ran mr olympia
look what would happen to those
bodybuilders they need a dana white type
is what you're saying
they need teddy moscow bro say that man
it's a person who
understands what you have to go out and
address
all the criticism i wouldn't be running
it in the the way i would run the model
is a very different way than i run my
insurance company it's a very different
way
it would be a i don't even want to see i
don't want to give the ideas
i'll tell you i'll tell you one major
thing i'm not going to do it until you
want to heat it up
yeah let's go athlete just needs to be
asked one question what do you want
that's it no i think i think if i feel
like that's like
the notebook right there what do you
want i think yeah if someone said
what do you want phil and just sat back
and listen
didn't and then you know a lot of
athletes are conditioned to not even
like know what to ask
because they haven't been asked those
questions i think at the end of the day
you want like for instance um
you know i never won an arnold classic
columbus ohio trophy right yeah i did
the arnold classic in europe so
one of the promoters was like phil you
got to do this show you got to do this
show for me
for you okay you're going to pay me to
show up
he was like what i said you know when
tiger woods goes yeah
tiger woods goes to one of these
invitationals because this is an
invitational
you you pay for his flight his hotel has
everything
you give him a signing fee what are you
gonna do for me
and you know what he says there won't be
any money is it all about the money
phil i said that's funny because
you flew here on private and i'm flying
here on business
you flew here on private to australia
are you nuts
so the lack of recruitment is what i'm
saying like
i cannot stand that [ __ ] you should say
whatever you want because at the end of
the day if i say
i want one of those cards right there i
want that mercedes
and you say here try drive mine for the
day
and i'll get you one next week you don't
think that i'm gonna train my ass off
even more
and more and more and more and more so i
think
you know if they don't offer anything if
they don't dangle a carrot
yeah in addition to the trophy you're
not going to get the athletes to stay
motivated
and you're not going to and when i say
this i say this with all sincerity
you're going to have bodybuilders that
are going to focus more on being
influencers
than competitors we don't need that we
don't need more influencers
we want the best less influence i want
to see the best on stage be focused just
on the show because that's what i did so
what's the carrot right now just a
trophy
yeah cover of a magazine maybe there was
there's no covers of magazines so
therefore i mean
the average bodybuilder is having to
rely on sponsorship
because the shows don't pay enough now i
i definitely feel like um the shows
could
you know i just feel like you know for
the olympia
you know i think there's a lot of
conversation that needs to happen i
think for the arnold classic there needs
to be a lot of conversation and at the
end of the day all they have to do is
just sit us down
you know if someone wanted me to do one
of the shows right
have they called when i said last time i
said my phone's on
you think anyone called they didn't
because sometimes
they don't want power to the player but
i think what happened with ufc
when conor mcgregor raised all hell
called dana white out and also
stuff and said you know i'll go back to
england i'll be nobody again
you don't think they had a conversation
they not only had a conversation they
probably asked them what he wanted
and if he didn't know he's like well i
have an idea for you we'll get you your
own liquor or this and that and the
other next thing you know you're doing
that you're doing this you're doing that
now he's walking around with that strut
you know doing his thing
actually what happened with habib as
well when habib wanted to retire dana
white said well hold on like let's have
a conference
david thanks david right there there he
goes nice dropping david yeah
pleasure but i think you were talking
trash about the produce but how much
but how much money did they make right
okay now you listen rule of thumb of
business take care of your number one
and they don't take care of the number
ones listen the way i judge you
uh you judge a uh man by the way he
treats his wife who's a good wife you
treat
you judge a woman by the way she treats
her husband who's a good husband who
does his part who does her part you
judge a parent by the way they treat you
judge who's a
kid that's doing his part you judge kids
based on how they take care of their mom
and dad who did their part i'm not going
to judge a kid whose
mom or dad is a deadbeat i'm not going
to sit there and tell but if a dad is
doing their part listen man you better
take care of this
you know what he did for you you know
what you're you judge a great business
based on how they treat their superstars
not stars yes stars but superstars
nba takes care of lebron james as well
as much as i disagree
it's their job mlb takes care of this
new guy
who is the first time honey all-star
both sides
they take care of me and then mike trout
they take care of you
and
the last thing you want is one of the
greatest sports sportsman's ever in your
sport to even
remotely be talking trash about your
sport i'm not saying that's what you're
doing i mean no i want
i want that i wonder but i'm telling you
what i am saying is
i want all athletes men women all
categories to be able to say i'm a pro
and i make a
pretty good living yeah all pros if
you're top 10 in the world at anything i
think you should still be able to
motivate the number 15 20 100 percent
out there
i may be the next phil heath not the
person anyways let's let's talk about
this
most i ever made in the minor leagues
most i ever made was 2 000
a month and they and that was what 10
years ago
you were hitting diggers i could hit a
little bit the baltimore freaking
orioles
their double a team most of those guys
are are
a back spasm away from the big leagues
they didn't
put them up in housing these guys are
still making 1900 bucks
and they defaulted on the team housing
these guys were sleeping
in their cars to play minor league
baseball
you understand what i'm saying now
people don't want college athletes to
get paid
people don't want in baseball just to go
back to what we're saying
if you don't if you don't get drafted
out of high school or if you decide to
go to college yeah you're not eligible
for three years same nfl rule
then whatever team drafts you which by
the way don't even get me started on the
draft the draft is the most evil thing
in the world on all sports we make a
spectacle out of it the draft is evil
it's an evil thing in every sport that
you don't get to choose who you play for
and your entire brand is dependent on
being picked by somebody that knows what
to do with you and your career
we call these guys busts these guys
aren't bust they're victims
most of them but not that sometimes by
the way and that's why the baltimore or
orioles the last time they won a world
series was 83.
three years of college okay five years
in the minors before you're a free agent
eight
years before you have any autonomy over
your career
imagine you coming out imagine you
coming out in any other industry
in any other industry you want to be a
financial advisor you want to be a
computer engineer
and microsoft says nah you got to come
work for us and this is what you have to
make
and you don't get to decide anything
about it for five years and if you have
a problem with it well there's
somebody that wants to be a computer
engineer show your gratitude be grateful
and then they wonder why these guys milk
every single penny fans want them to get
their guys to give them a hometown
discount sorry brah
every single dollar whoever wants me i
get
the entire game is getting to the second
contract and then that's that
that's that man if you get to the second
contract the same thing with guys guys
who would do whatever they had to do
guys who juiced got and everybody was
like these guys are cheaters i never
felt bad about those guys even once
matter of fact i was like you know what
good for them i didn't have the balls to
do it
i was afraid that if i got caught
juicing they'd go back to all my college
stats they'd be like this guy's been
juicing since college all those records
that's garbage
the player of the year garbage it's all
it's all been and so i never did it
because i was worried about legacy
instead of worrying about getting that
connection
by the way that's another conversation
that i would i would address that
conversation
front and center legalize juicing
listen and let me explain to what i mean
by legal not because it's
legal already anyways it's not people
want to get their hands on it they're
going to be able to get their hands on
it but if you're talking about
legalizing
the whole libertarian argument you want
to use it use it
you think it makes you better like youth
chad nichols said it best
he said look i can use everything and
anything out there i'm still not going
to win mr olympia
okay some people think just because you
take stuff you're going to go out there
and win
you think just because you take steroids
you're going to be able to hit 74
bombers i dare you to do
it go do it don't be very boxing pretty
good yeah yeah go ahead and do it go see
if you can pull
basically saying do what you all you
want with your body no matter what
whatever
the point i'm trying it doesn't
necessarily help in all sports
you know in some sports if you don't do
it you're going to destroy yourself in
football like you don't think guys
you don't think lebron's using gh you
you seriously look at that
physique and you don't think the
allegation there patrick
wait a minute though do you actually
think a guy at that level who's saying i
spend one and a half million dollars
taking care of my body every year you
don't think he is
using this i think a 265 pound man who
somehow has gained muscle mass
over 20 years while he runs five miles a
night and has a receding hairline has
taken steroids
yeah no it doesn't make again you gotta
go after his hairline bro let's stick to
the facts here but here's
the point don't want that by the way the
point obviously the problem
the point i'm trying to make to you is
my argument today a lot of people are
looking to say
did patcher say legalize steroids bro
prohibition
marijuana what else you want to go with
okay
gambling casinos was illegal people said
there's no way you know what's going to
be attracted to casinos
you ever been to this crime all this
stuff that you're talking about
it's let the man make a choice if it
makes you
better and you got the advan competitive
advantage but if i can use it and you
can use it
hey it's illegal but if i can't no
problem right now it's just
incentivizing people that are willing to
break the rules
and that's the part like sammy said
something you want to take take the guns
away from good people
i will always have guns he says i sammy
the bull garvano will always have a gun
take it away from us i'll always have it
i want to transition to carlos mancia i
think what you're saying is
let the man choose choice what are your
thoughts on it though real quick
are you talking like he's straight up on
gh and everything i mean i do like
what i do i just think people should be
able to hey hey
gave him a flashback from the boy scouts
yeah like we better touch on the boys
because i know he was touched hey so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye